Why did you sign up for this online general psychology course? Or why did I
take twelve months of training to try to get to the top of half dome at
Yosemite National Park. Why did you wait in line for three hours to see the new
Star Trek film? Or why did I order a double cheeseburger and chocolate shake,
even though I know they're not good for me? Well, maybe the cheeseburger makes
me feel good, so emotion can play a role. Or maybe I ordered it because I was
just plain hungry.
>> Well, in order to do all the things that Susan just talked about, you can need
motivation, and that's exactly what we're going to talk about in this lesson.
First we're going to start with talking about the theories of motivation. Then
we'll talk about how motivations actually drive our behaviours. And we're going
to end the lesson by talking about emotion.
>> That's right. Now the word motivation comes from the Latin verb, which means to
move. And so here we're interested in our movements and actions and what
determines those movements and actions. And now Lauren is going to start
talking a little bit about motivation in depth.
>> Let's go do that.